so you're in a third world country and
you want to get rich normally this would
be impossible because it's a third world
country but there is a special moment in
time in some third world countries where
it is possible to get rich with relative
ease see some third world countries go
through this rare Goldilocks phase a
phase where they're on the brink of
transitioning from a third world country
to more of a second world country and
for some maybe even a first world
country during this phase there's a ton
of expansion and growth money but more
importantly there's a lot of corruption
and bribery that goes along with that
expansion growth and money because
remember it's still a third world
country at Hearts it happened in Russia
in the 90s when the Russian economy
became privatized which gave rise to the
Russian oligarchs it happened in South
Korea during the 60s and 70s Korea just
came out of the Korean War and the
government wanted to give cheap loans to
Korean businesses to boost the economy
which gave rise to Korea's most powerful
families like Samsung LG Hyundai these
families are practically Above the Law
today in Korea their power and wealth is
insane and they solidified their power
during this Goldilocks phase of Korea
and it also happened in China with this
astronomical rise in the 90s where
magically China's Parliament is home to
over a hundred billionaires I'm sure
they made their money legitimately so if
you found yourself in this unique
situation in a third world country
turning into a second world country if
you play your cards right you can use
this opportunity to become one of the
most powerful wealthiest people in your
entire country a true modern day
oligarch but you gotta know exactly how
to finesse the system the right way and
this is your guide because guess what
this exact scenario has been playing out
over the last few decades in a
little-known country called India and
one man has been using this once in a
lifetime opportunity to gobble up all of
India his name goto madani India's
Rockefeller adani is the perfect example
for you to follow adani has skyrocketed
into not only one of the most powerful
men in India but at one point he even
surpassed Bezos as the second richest
person in the world on the outside it
looks like he's this incredible business
genius that ever everything he touches
turns to Gold but you and I know
difference you and I know that although
goto madani is very good at business his
Empire is built on corruption bribery
being in bed with India's prime minister
an insane amount of debts and a whole
lot of mysterious disappearances and
deaths at least according to one
Anonymous person online for what that's
worth and this is how you can do the
same
[Music]
one of adani's most valuable assets on
his client to the top is also his most
mysterious a multi-million dollar art
collection never seen by the public see
collecting art isn't just a hobby for
adani he's just following in the
footsteps of the biggest banks and
institutions in the world because right
now all of them are quietly investing 30
to 50 of their portfolios into
alternative assets one of those
alternative assets is fine arts as
stated by Goldman Sachs money managers
say demand for art is skyrocketing right
now because investors are racing in
especially with a typical portfolio
already down 20 for the year now you may
be asking yourself but how am I supposed
to afford a Picasso or something like
that well that is where our Channel
partner Masterworks comes in Masterworks
is a platform that allows anyone to
invest in high-end art from Legends like
Picasso and Banksy for a fraction of the
full cost instead of buying a piece on
your own they break the ownership of a
work of art into shares removing the
high barrier to entry so you can buy and
sell shares of Fine Arts and because
people are rushing into Fine Art
Masterworks has been seeing more demand
than ever and it's been paying off huge
for Masterworks investors to date
they've sold six paintings from their
collection for an average net return of
29 to put into context how amazing that
is they sold a painting in August for a
33.1 net return even as the s p was down
17 for the year they've done so well
that there's actually a wait list to
join Masterworks but you can click the
link below for Priority Access so pause
the video and click the link below to
get Priority Access to Masterworks
before it's too late
thank you
step one is getting your feet wet
because if you're gonna become the most
powerful oligarch in your country even
with all the corruption and favors
you're still gonna need to be really
good at business so start a business you
can start small and once you've learned
the basics you can move on to more
advanced topics like how to import Goods
without authorization from the
government or how to skip out on paying
taxes you know the kind of stuff you
would learn in business school once
you're pretty well versed you're gonna
have to get a little more intentional on
how you expand you gotta take a page out
of the great tycoons before you like
Carnegie and Rockefeller where your goal
is not to just own one business but own
the whole entire chain remember you're
still in a second-rate country this
isn't America where there are
anti-monopoly laws you're free to gobble
it all up like the robber barons of
industrial America and this is exactly
how adoni began his upward climb to the
top of India's economy it started in the
late 70s when his brother vinod just
opened the Plastics Factory and asked
adani if he would move back to his
hometown to help him run it adani
reluctantly agreed and when he got there
he wasn't impressed profit margins were
way too low and he knew they could be
making a lot more cash and because adani
grew up in a big family with not enough
food to go around he always seemed to
have this insatiable thirst for money
so
he started to look for loopholes in the
system to see what he could get away
with he came to learn one of the
benefits of being in a country like this
one day instead of paying the government
fees to import the bulk PVC granules
they needed for the factory adani
partnered with a business who was
already approved by the government and
imported what he needed through their
system at a fraction of the cost hmm
pretty cool the world of business
started to feel like a game a game he
could win it so he started entering
every vital sector of India's growing
economy power plants mines he even
opened up his own network of private
ports under the name of adani
Enterprises limited so he can make money
off of his own imports and exports as
well as the imports and exports of all
the other businesses in India he also
opened this chain of businesses at the
perfect time in Indian history when
tariffs on Imports were lowered and the
control of the government over Indian
businesses had loosened exponential this
was the moment childhood self had been
waiting for it's the dawn of capitalism
and he's in the perfect position to
become the richest man India has ever
seen
[Music]
the leadership
of one man
has made
all different
[Music]
taking advantage of little loopholes can
only get you so far what you need to do
now is get on the good side of the guys
who make the rules so if you ever need
to I don't know open a coal mine that
ends up polluting the water supply of an
entire Village or clear 3 000 hectares
of preserved the land to build your
factory on it you can do it without
anyone from the government giving you a
hard time sure you can get in bed with
lower level government officials but why
not go big or go home aim for the Prime
Minister but don't go for the Prime
Minister that's already in office he's
guaranteed to already have a bunch of
people asking him for stuff every day so
it'll be harder to build a solid
relationship instead look for an
ambitious politician who is aiming to
become Prime Minister that will be much
easier and he'll be easier to bribe this
is why it's so important to already have
a decent little business Empire going on
by this point you've got to have some
resources at your disposal and a track
record to show for and once you get his
attention tell him about some in
interesting business deals that will
enrich not just you but him paint a
picture of all the riches you're going
to share with him how you'll fund his
campaign help him get into office and
how all he needs to do is once he gets
into office tweak some legislation here
and there to favor your business pass
all the most lucrative government
contracts to you and
maybe look the other way once in a while
when problems pop up if you come off
confident and competent if you sound
like you have a hundred percent
conviction in what you're saying like
you know how the system works maybe slip
some cash into his pocket in the process
to tease him with what's to come he'll
probably say it there's just simply too
much money staring at him in the face
for any mortal to say no and when adani
met Narendra Modi the future Prime
Minister of India it was a match made in
heaven adani did everything imaginable
to make sure he became modi's number one
man like offering to fund modi's
electoral campaign so once Modi was
elected prime minister in 2014 Modi gave
adani all the preferential treatment
Modi gave him ownership of six major
airports in India even though he had no
experience in aviation he fully
supported nadani's Coal Mine Adventure
Modi even sold him state-owned land
priced at only one cent per square meter
so he could rent it back to Indian
citizens for eleven dollars
no wonder that ever since Modi came into
office adani's personal net worth has
multiplied by 230 percent and his
business it has expanded 12-fold in
return adani continues to give his
friend in power unconditional support he
defends him publicly whenever his
leadership is being questioned he
accompanies him on state visits and he
even gave the Prime Minister his own
Fleet of adani brand private jets but
this is just the beginning once you have
the prime minister in your pocket it's
time to pour gasoline on the Fire
[Music]
it's fair to assume that your guy in
Power isn't gonna stay in power forever
sometimes rulers of countries like this
do stay in power for a really long time
like the royal family of Sri Lanka but
it's not always guaranteed these
countries are on a tightrope so you want
to expand and Gobble up as much of the
economy as fast as you can the problem
is you're definitely not going to have
enough savings to expand at this scale
but worry not because that is where the
magic of debt comes in borrowing money
to buy up more of the economy the
problem is borrowing money in third or
second world countries can be kind of
tricky but not when you're friends with
the Prime Minister get your prime
minister to convince these lending
institutions to lend you as much money
as you want while competitors are trying
to get a few measly loans here and there
through regular channels lenders will be
throwing more loans at you than you can
spend here's a graph of all the 30
billion dollars worth of debt adani has
used to fuel his astronomical rise
oh
[Music]
foreign
having the prime minister in your pocket
can only take you so far there are a lot
of people in the government the prime
minister can't Corral all of them to
support you no so you've got all the
money you need to expand now you just
need to make sure you bribe the rest of
the government officials you gotta make
sure that no one is going to get in your
way not the police not the Port
Authority no one for example want to
extract more coal than what's normally
allowed due to risk of air pollution
simply make some donations to the
government officials in charge of these
restrictions and they'll be magically
taken care of want to open a mine in a
sleepy fishing Village but don't want to
go through the authorization process pay
the Port Authorities police and Customs
to stay quiet about it and you're golden
finest documentation of corruption in
this country that Independent India has
ever seen there are Pages after pages of
documentation of how adani Enterprises
was involved in electing my knows
illegally export thousands and thousands
of tons of INR from India abroad and
there are detailed documentation and
tabulation of bright Spade at various
levels and how it was all manipulated
recently adani bribed the Indian
government with very generous donations
so Modi can make a new rule in his favor
Modi mandated that coal companies in
India must use 10 imported coal which is
around 10 times more expensive than
locally mined Indian coal even though
there is no shortage who owns all the
ports are done so now who makes a ton of
money importing coal adani and when
adani wanted to open an iron mine in
balakri a quaint Village on the west
coast of India he wanted to make sure he
could extract every last scrap of iron
out of his mind but he didn't want to be
restricted by any kind of annoying
environmental regulations or laws on how
much iron he can extract and Export so
he bribe the police the Port Authorities
Customs authorities and politicians so
everyone would just shut their mouths
and let him mine his iron in peace
according to the report records seized
from the bellicari office of adani
Enterprises showed that it
systematically bribed the host of
regulators public officials and
politicians
the ombudsman's report detailed the
corrupt payments
money has been regularly paid to Port
Authorities Customs authorities the
police department mines and geology and
even to mlas and MPS all these payments
were not shown in the balance sheet of
the company unaccountered and paid in
cash and why has he gotten away with
this for so long because even if someone
rats him out he's protective That's The
Power of having the man in office behind
your back
foreign
[Music]
part siphoning money out of your company
into your own pocket see money in your
giant conglomerate isn't actually yours
you have investors other people that own
a part of your company and therefore own
a part of the profits in your company
that is no fun so you gotta move as much
of that cash into your own personal
piggy bank as possible and you gotta do
it without any shareholders noticing and
the way you do that is with secrecy
Havens you may have heard about secrecy
Havens from previous videos on this
channel but in a nutshell secrecy Havens
are places where they respect the
privacy of wealthy clients such as
yourself allowing you to create shell
companies that you control but aren't
tied to you they act like Anonymous bank
accounts that can't be traced back to
you kind of like an anonymous crypto
wallet if you want to think about it
that way so set up shell companies in
these Havens one in the Cayman Islands
one and Mauritius and one in Singapore
it's always good to diversify make your
brother the CEO of these companies so
it's not obvious you're the one behind
all of this and oh just to be safe
you're also going to get him to legally
change his last name from adani to Shaw
just to make sure no one can connect the
dots now that you have your offshore
Empire set up you just gotta make sure
that the companies who buy your Coleman
stuff send the payment to these shell
companies in these tax Havens and not
the adani group companies in India that
way this money never touches your hands
on paper but it's still under your
control by doing this you give the
Indian people the illusion that their
economy is growing without giving any
Financial benefit to them besides the
people you directly employed and your
shareholders they're getting played too
because all the real money is going
directly into your pocket through your
shell companies instead of the adani
group remember we want control over this
money not ownership who cares if it's
your brother that owns the shell company
on paper that's the point you're the
brother in charge between you and him
you obviously have the final say in how
this money gets used as long as you can
spend the money as if it's your own
that's all that matters a recent report
came out showing that 13 out of the 26
Dani subsidiaries in Australia are
registered in the Cayman Islands and in
2016 adani was accused of siphoning
money out of his company into an
offshore account in Mauritius another
tax Haven according to a report filed by
the dri the adani group bought over 100
million dollars worth of electrical
equipment from a company in Dubai but
when you follow the paper trail this
Dubai company turned out to be owned by
a series of shell companies that led
right back to a trust owned by who do
you know adani's brother but instead of
paying the actual price he paid about
400 percent more for the goods so in
effect adani was allegedly funneling
money out of the adani group into his
own pocket via an offshore account they
appear to be Crooks from all this
evidence that the Department of Revenue
intelligence has Unearthed
they are clearly they clearly appear to
be Crooks on
[Music]
the way in which
[Music]
one of the really cool things about
being a de facto oligarch is that if
pesky journalists start bashing you all
you need to do is buy out the TV and
media channels where they're bashing you
and then change the narrative
for adani his Target was NDTV one of
India's most beloved alternative news
sources adani really didn't like how
they portrayed him so he did some
research and found out that the owners
of NDTV had to take out a loan years ago
from a company called vcpl in order to
keep a majority stake in their news
station and maintain their journalistic
integrity
adani also discovered that they never
paid back the loan that loan represented
29.18 of the ownership of the company so
he quickly Acquired vcpl and converted
the loan into that 29.18 stake position
now he owns almost one-third of NDTV the
owners of NDTV never saw it coming go
adani and when adani couldn't get enough
control of the media through actually
buying up news platforms he sued
investigative journalists like paranjoy
guja takurta who wrote about adani
group's many scandals for the economic
Times and the wire and when pot enjoy
couldn't pay up he just forced him to
resign it's okay nobody needs that kind
of noise anyway
[Music]
Gautam adani an Indian businessman who
made his fortune in shipping and coal
production has officially become the
world's second richest person yeah so he
did it adani became the richest man
India has ever seen
but there's one little detail one little
string that's been pulling at him ever
since he set up that chain of businesses
back in the mid 80s because he owns
every rung of the ladder if too many
rungs fall off the whole structure
collapses and these days his chain of
businesses is starting to weaken India
is running out of coal and what good are
coal power plants and coal ports without
a healthy source of well coal this is
why he's approached Australia home of
the largest coal deposits in the world
for permission to dig a mine near
Queensland near a cold Port called
Abbott point that he conveniently
already happens to own see this is the
problem with owning the whole chain the
raw materials you need to make the whole
system run could disappear one day but
he will not let this structure this
house of cards fall so he does the same
old routine he sends a very generous
donation to the Australian government
bribes all the right people and gets all
the pro coal lobbyists to convince the
parliament on his behalf today if you
look at adani's Empire it's more like a
house of cards House of Cards built upon
a giant heap of debt but who knows a man
this powerful with this many people in
his pocket might be able to keep it all
from collapsing and even if it does you
can bet that he's already got enough set
aside offshore so that he's set for life
adani's Minds have caused immense damage
both to the environment and the health
of the Indian people the dust from
adani's coal mine in Goa India is
causing breathing problems in children
who live nearby and local doctors are
claiming that there's been an influx of
respiratory disorders in their patients
ever since it opened
but this is nothing new plenty of
companies have done irreparable damage
to the environment and one of those
companies is Monsanto who sprayed a
highly toxic chemical Called Agent
Orange over Vietnam during the Vietnam
war to this very day children born
within the family line of the agent
orange victims have irreversible birth
defects but that was far from the only
evil thing Monsanto has done they've had
a long history of experimenting with
chemicals and their own employees have
felt the effects they're also the
company that kinda owns the world's food
supply through their genetically
modified seeds
but this stuff gets dark like a little
too dark to be posted publicly on
YouTube without getting demonetized this
is why we decided to release a private
uncensored full-length documentary on
Monsanto only available to members of
this Channel all you have to do to get
instant access to Monsanto the company
that owns the world's food supply and
top and to other secret docks that are
just too dark to post publicly is to
click the join button below and unlike
University we are not going to charge
you thousands of dollars only to leave
you in the dark about how the world
really works all it takes is five
dollars a month to learn about what
they'll never teach you in school and
there's a refund policy too unlike most
YouTube memberships so if you're not
happy with the membership just email us
within your first month of joining and
we will refund your five dollars right
away no questions asked after your first
month there is no refund scroll down and
click that join button below now you
won't regret it
I personally love making these videos on
you know how to get rich in third world
countries because it shows like really
how great the world is and how there's
really no rules if you really wanted to
you can find your way around every
single rule out there so if you enjoyed
this video we make documentaries just
like this one every single week on money
power war and crime so that you can
learn how the world really works instead
of becoming a victim to it so if you
like that philosophy if you want to be
more dangerous click that subscribe
button below you can follow me on
Instagram but that is going to wrap it
up thanks for being part of the watch to
the end Club stay dangerous out there
and I will see you guys in the next one
thank you
[Music]
[Music]